kiskit runtime free courses from the ibm
center for cloud training and the ibm
data power gateway x3 all on this
episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
last week the ibm quantum team announced
two significant updates to the kiskit
runtime programming environment what
does kisskit you ask it's a hardware
agnostic software development kit that
gives you the ability to build compile
run and analyze quantum circuits and
quantum programs
it essentially makes it easy to control
the interaction between quantum software
and quantum hardware
but as quantum computing matures the
field is increasingly attracting new
categories of users such as algorithm
developers and application researchers
these users want results without getting
into the intricacies of hardware or
dealing with quantum noise
and that's where kiskit runtime comes in
released last year it introduces new
layers of abstraction that make it easy
to access high performance quantum
computing systems run quantum circuits
at speed and get error mitigated results
teams launched a new update of kiskit
runtime one that brings an array of
novel features and capabilities into two
new primitives that will give more
programmers an entry point to the
service
regular kiskit users can also now access
our premium quantum systems via ibm
cloud with pay-as-you-go pricing
so if you're looking for the right time
and the best way to dip your toe into
quantum programming these two kiskit
runtime updates may be just what you
need to get started
check out the blog post i have linked
below for the full details
next up there's a worldwide gap in cloud
skills for businesses and individuals
and 79 percent of companies say they
need advanced cloud capabilities for
their employees
for over 100 years now training and
education have been central to ibm's
business practice and that's why we're
proud to announce that all the ibm cloud
courses offered through the ibm center
for cloud training are available at no
charge that's right free
the center for cloud training offers
role-based training and certifications
like cloud architect cloud developer and
cloud sre you can also work towards
specialty certifications and security
financial services satellite and
devsecops
our programs are designed for
large-scale on-demand worldwide
upskilling and we're excited to help it
professionals hone their skills advance
their careers and help their
organizations thrive
to learn more hit the link below
finally to wrap things up this episode
i'm excited to announce the newest
generation of data power gateway
appliances with the ibm datapower
gateway x3
this latest model continues the long
line of application gateways from ibm
building on the capabilities for
securing integrating and automating
business and it applications and
services
the new x3 is designed to extend ibm
datapower's capabilities with improved
performance security and usability
features
x3 also equips businesses with a
powerful application gateway to protect
control optimize integrate and automate
their modern traditional and hybrid
cloud workloads
to learn more about this new model and
the timing of the launch check out the
link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description in
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now
you